how's it going everybody it's Warren and
Avengers in game is only 11 days away
and with Avengers in games so close to
coming out the theories and speculations
have just been going crazy but right now
there's a theory going around that I
think makes a lot of sense that is about
Captain America wielding the Infinity
Gauntlet he's pretty good at that right
this is something that I think we all
think is going to happen in Avengers end
game but this theory offers a little bit
of a twist to Captain America wielding
the gauntlet so we'll talk about all of
that and break it down in this video but
first if you're new to my channel be
sure to subscribe
I do monthly giveaways and currently
giving away a life-sized Infinity
Gauntlet and a glow-in-the-dark painting
of fan oohs by globe I though I'll talk
more about the giveaway at the end of
the video but to enter the giveaway all
you have to do is be subscribed to my
channel like this video and comment down
below with your thoughts and your
favorite superhero or villain so again
this theory is that Captain America will
wield the Infinity Gauntlet in Avengers
end game but he's not going to die when
he wields it and undoes the snap a lot
of people think that Captain America
will wield the Infinity Gauntlet and
Avengers in game but will die because of
all the stones as power however this may
not be the case in avengers endgame
Captain America may be able to wield the
Infinity Gauntlet and not die from its
power but could actually control its
power in order to understand this theory
we have to go back to the scene in
Avengers infinity war where Captain
America is able to briefly hold off
Thanos one of the biggest questions
about Avengers infinity war was how was
Captain America able to hold off the mad
Titan Thanos especially when he was
wearing the Infinity Gauntlet there is
no possible way that Captain America is
stronger than Thanos after all the Hulk
is way stronger than Captain America and
the Hulk wasn't strong enough to take on
Thanos
well reddit users and perky checks says
that it wasn't about Captain America
being stronger than Thanos but it was
about Captain America's ability to
manipulate the Infinity Gauntlet so that
it was working against Thanos for the
moment if you think about this it makes
a ton of sense and it goes all the way
back to the Avengers age of Ultron where
Captain America was able to slightly
move Muhl near moving mule near had
nothing to do with strength but had to
do with who was worthy enough to wield
it
well the same could apply for the
Infinity Gauntlet after all it is made
of metal the same metal that mule near
was made after now of course mule near
had a worthiness charm on it placed on
it by Odin and it's safe to say the
Infinity Gauntlet does not have that
same charm on it however it doesn't mean
that worthiness and will don't come into
play we know that the Infinity stones
are somewhat alive they are conscious in
fact all throughout infinity war we see
the mine stone worn vision about Thanos
coming and the Infinity stones represent
different aspects of the universe and
although Thanos is an extremely powerful
being with an extremely powerful will to
execute his plan the Infinity stones
most likely did not want half of the
universe extinct after all again
the mine stone was trying to warn vision
about Thanos like it didn't want Thanos
to obtain it so perhaps when Captain
America was able to hold off Thanos
wearing the Infinity Gauntlet it was
because the Infinity stones recognized
his will his good will we all know that
Captain America Steve Rogers is pure of
heart
I mean it's Captain America so maybe the
Infinity stones recognize this and
really want to perform Captain America's
will instead of famous as will and maybe
that will enable Captain America to be
the one to wield the Infinity Gauntlet
and Avengers endgame it doesn't actually
mean that he won't die after performing
the snap but perhaps his will and pure
heart are strong enough for him to at
least wield the Infinity Gauntlet and
perform the snap before being
disintegrated but let me know what you
think about this theory do you think
Captain America's will and worthiness
make him eligible to wield the Infinity
Gauntlet before being disintegrated and
do you indeed think that it will be
Captain America who wields it in
Avengers endgame let me know your
thoughts in the comments down below and
again don't forget to subscribe to my
channel like this video and comment down
below with your thoughts and your
favorite superhero so you can enter the
giveaway for the Infinity Gauntlet and
the glow-in-the-dark painting by global
bow you can also find more of his art at
globe abode com and of course if you're
new be sure to subscribe to my channel
so you can stay up to date on everything
relating to Avengers in game and all
things Marvel as always thank you all so
much for watching woof woof
[Music]